now i was talking about you
being a scientist on earth but say you
were a scientist uh they were shipped
over to europa
to investigate if there's life what
would you look for
in terms of signs of life life
is unmistakable i would say the way that
life
transforms a planet surrounding it
is not the kind of thing that you would
expect from the physical laws alone
so it's i would say that as soon as
life arises it creates this
compartmentalization
it starts pushing things away it starts
sort of keeping things inside that
herself
and there's a whole signature
that you can see from that so when i was
organizing my meaning of life symposium
my
my my friend was an astrophysicist um
basically
uh we were deciding on what would be the
themes for the for the symposium
and then i said well we're going to have
biology we're going to have physics and
she's like
come on biology is just a small part of
physics
[Laughter]
everything is a small part of physics
and i mean
in in many ways it is but my immediate
answer was no no wait
life challenges physics it supersedes
physics
it it sort of fights against physics
and that's what i would look for in
europa i would basically look for this
fight against physics for anything that
sort of
signatures of not just entropy at work
not just things diffusing away
not just gravitational pulls but
clear signatures of you remember when i
was talking earlier about this whole
selection for environment selection for
biospheres for ecosystems
for this multi-organism
form of life and i think that's sort of
the the first thing that
you can look for you know chemical
signatures that are not
simply predicted from the reactions you
would get randomly such a beautiful
way to look at life so you're basically
leveraging some energy source
to enable you to resist the physics of
the universe
fighting against physics but that's
that's the first transformation if you
look at humans
we're way past that what do you mean by
transformation so so
basically there's there's layers i sort
of see
life you know when we talk about the
meaning of life
life can be construed at many levels we
talked about life in the simplest form
of sort of the ignition of evolution and
that's sort of the basic definition that
you can check off yes
it's alive but when alexander the great
was asked to whom do you owe
your life to your teachers
or to your parents and alexander the
great
answered i owe to my parents
the zine the life itself and i owe to my
teachers the
f zine like euphony f means good
the opposite of cacophony which means
you know bad
so f zine in his
words was basically living
a human life a proper life so basically
we can go from the zen
to the f zine and that transformation
has
taken several additional leaps
so basically you know life on europa i'm
pretty sure has gotten to the stage of
a makes b makes c makes a again
but getting to the fzine is a whole
other
um level and that level requires
cooperation that level requires
altruism that level requires
specialization
remember how we're talking about the rna
specializing into dna for storage
proteins and then compartmentalizations
and if you look at prokaryotic life
there's no nucleus
it's all one soup of things
intermingling if you look at
eukaryotic life again you for true
good you know so a eukaryote
basically has a nucleus and that's where
you compartmentalize further
the organization of the information
storage
from all of the daily activities if you
look at a
you know human body plan or any animal
you have a comparablization of the
germline
you basically have one lineage that will
basically be saved for the future
generations
and everything outside that lineage is
almost superfluous
if you think about it the rest of your
body all it does
is ensure that that lineage will make it
to the next generation
that these germ lines will make to the
next generation the rest is packaging
i'm sorry to be so blunt yeah and if you
look at nutrition
you know where deterostomes what does
the third stone mean
deutero means second where
this is the second mouth the first mouth
is actually down here it's the esophagus
so dirt or stones have evolved a second
layer of eating kind of like alien with
the two mouths
yeah so you can think of us as alien
where the first mouth is up here
and then the second mouth is down there
is that of course is the first mouth
just the
the the physical manipulation of the
food to make it more correct
correct and basically again you know if
you look at if you look at a worm
it's an extremely simple life form it
basically has a mouth it has an anus
and it has you know just some organs in
between that consume the food and just
spit spit out poo
yeah humans are basically a fancy form
of that
so you basically have the mouth you have
the digestive tract
and then you have limbs to get better at
getting food you have
eyesight hearing etc to get better
getting food
yeah and then you have of course the
germline and all of this food part
it's just auxiliary to the germline so
you basically have layers of
addition of comparablization of
specialization
on top of this zine to get all the way
to the earth zine
yeah so like the warm is like windows 95
very few features
very basic and then us humans are like
windows vista
or windows 10 whatever it is well a few
innovations beyond that but yeah yeah
and then all right where i don't know
where windows 10 000 let's put it that
way so okay
that's such a fascinating way to look at
life as a set of transformations
exactly so like is there some
interesting transformations to our
history here on earth that like appeal
to you of course so and what are the
most
brilliant innovations and
transformations yeah yeah i mean
this is such a fascinating question of
course like you know we're talking about
basic basic life forms and we'll talk
about eukaryotic life forms
and then the next big transformation is
multicellular life forms
where the specialization separates the
germline
from everything else that accompanies it
and sort of carries it
and then that specialization then sort
of has this
massive new innovation like above the
second mouth
which is this massive brain and this
massive brain
is basically something that arises
much much later on basically you know
notochords like having the first spinal
cord
this whole concept that along with these
very simple layers
you basically now have a coordinating
agent
and this coordinating agent is starting
to make decisions
and remember when we're talking about uh
free will
i mean you know as a worm is hunting for
food
oh it has plenty of free will it can
choose to you know
follow chemotaxis to the left for
chemotaxis to the right and maybe that's
free will because it's unpredictable
beyond a certain level so you basically
now have
more and more decision-making and
coordination of all of these different
body parts and organs
by a central operating system a central
machine that basically will control
the rest of the body
you